several unemployment claimants have
reached out to eight news now about an
issue happening with bank of america
unemployment accounts joe mohler first
brought us this story last week
and has an update for us this evening hi
joe
yeah hey there well centering this story
on friday dozens of people have reached
out to me with similar situations all
dieter did respond and they say they are
working
on this with bank of america and today
we were able to learn
what people should be doing uh next if
they are in this
situation i tried to take
400 out of that money and it says
insufficient funds via gracias says her
unemployment debit account was closed
after reporting stolen money last month
so then december 4th my i called back
because there's no money in my account
and they said oh we close your account
she says dieter is still paying her
benefits
she doesn't know where to or how to
access the money now because she says
neither dieter or bank of america have
been able to reopen that account
how can i resolve this problem i said
come on i haven't received any checks
for four weeks now friday we reached out
to dieter after hearing similar stories
they got back to us explaining they are
working with the bank on this
they say for a limited number of
claimants debit cards may be erroneously
frozen or blocked
valid individual cards that are frozen
blocked or closed will take five to
seven days to pass through the full
verification process to be reopened
we spoke to teresa crook on friday about
this problem she called dieter back this
week
this is what they had just worked out i
gather with bank of america i was told
that i needed to
email over some identification
things for them to verify i was indeed
who i said i was
the problem now is getting the alleged
stolen money back
she tries to get information from the
bank they have sent me letters saying my
claim is closed
they won't give me any information i
have not been reimbursed
we have reached out to bank of america
regarding a number of claims including
the one you just heard there and we have
yet to hear back
the status of those we also reached out
to dieter on what exactly clayman should
be doing
uh crookum there who just shared her
story she actually gave us a number that
she used that she was able to get
through to the fraud department
uh we're gonna go ahead and put that on
this story up on our website on
eightnewsnow.com if you wanted to try
that
to start your id verification process as
well reporting live joe moller 8 news
now